[CREAKING] [CLICKING]
[SQUEAKING] [RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: We
just started a new unit
on graph theory,
which is going to be
sort of our focus for the next
couple of lectures in 6006.
And so I thought we'd give
it a little bit of review
at the beginning the
lecture because, as usual,
I've muddled together
a lot of notions
in our previous lecture, and
then start with some new ideas.
So basically, in our
previous lecture,
we talked about an algorithm
called breadth-first search.
And then almost always
you see that paired
with a second algorithm
called depth-first search.
And following tradition,
and basically logic,
we'll do the same
thing in 006 today.
But in any event,
for today we'll
stick to the technical material.
So as a little bit of
review, I guess actually,
the one thing I didn't
do on this slide
was actually draw a graph.
So we should probably
start with that.
So if you recall, graph is a
collection of nodes or vertices
depending--
I don't know, is it like
a European American thing
or something-- and edges.
So here's an example,
which as usual, I'm
not managing to draw
particularly clearly.
So this graph is
kind of like a cycle.
So I have directed edges
here, here, here, and here.
And of course, there are
many kind of variations
on the theme, right?
So our basic sort of
definition of a graph
is that we have
some set V, which
is like the set of vertices.
And then we have a set
E, which is set of edges.
And this was a
subset of V cross V.
And this is nothing more than
fancy notation for saying
that an edge is a pair
of vertices, like a from
and a to vertex.
Of course, there are many
variations on this theme.
You could have a directed
versus an undirected graph.
So this one is directed, meaning
the edges look like arrows.
If they didn't have arrowheads,
they'd be undirected.
We define something called a
simple graph where you have
essentially no repeated edges.
So for instance, you
can't do something
like this where you have
the same edge twice.
And then there are a couple
of different definitions
that were kind of useful.
So in particular-- I'm going
to erase this, whoops--
useless edge here.
Maybe make my graph
slightly more interesting.
So add another edge going
in the reverse direction.
So maybe I have--
I'm going to give my vertices
labels. x, y, z, and w.
Then we talked
about the neighbors
of a given vertex, which
are the vertices that you
can reach by following edges
in or out of your vertex.
So in particular, the
outgoing neighbors,
which we sort of implicitly
defined in our previous lecture
but didn't call it out, we're
going to notate with Adj+.
And these are all of
the things that you
can reach by going out of
a vertex into the next one.
So for example, Adj+ of
w is going to be the set
of vertices.
We'll notice I can get from
w to y and also from w to z.
Yeah.
So.
Nope, nope.
y comma z.
OK.
So to continue just our tiny
amount of review for the day,
remember that a graph--
there are many different ways
to represent a graph.
The sort of brain
dead one would be just
like a big long list of edges.
But of course,
for our algorithms
it's not a particularly
efficient way
to check things like, does
this edge exist in my graph.
So the basic
representation that I
think we're mostly working
from in this course
is to think of a graph like a
set of vertices, each of which
maps to another set of vertices.
So roughly every vertex
maybe stores its outgoing set
of edges.
And so this is kind of
nice because, of course,
very quickly we can
answer questions like,
is this edge inside
of our graph?
Or we can iterate
over the neighbors
of a vertex and so on, which
are the kind of typical things
that we do in a lot
of graph algorithms.
And then finally, in
our previous lecture,
we started talking about paths.
So a path is like
a chain of vertices
that can get me from one vertex
to the other only following
edges of my graph.
There is a term that
I think I forgot
to define last time
because it didn't really
matter a ton, which is a
simple path, which is just
a path that doesn't have the
same vertex more than once.
And then, of course, there
are many different questions
you could ask about a
graph that are basically
different problems
involving computing paths.
So for instance, the shortest
path between two vertices
is sort of our canonical
one in graph theory.
Or you could ask questions
about reachability and so on.
So there's our basic review
from our previous lecture.
Does our course staff have any
questions about things so far?
Excellent.
OK.
And there's one additional
piece of terminology
that I fudged a little
bit last time-- or rather,
my co-instructor suggested a
bit of an attitude adjustment.
So I thought I'd better
clarify really quick.
There's this interesting
phrase, linear time,
which we all know and love
in computer science theory.
And this sort of implicit thing,
especially in this course,
is that when we
say linear time, we
mean in the size of the input.
Right?
And so if we have a linear
time graph algorithm, well,
how much space does it
take to store a graph?
Well, we need a list of
vertices and a list of edges,
if nothing else.
So a reasonable way to interpret
this phrase linear time
is that it's an algorithm
that looks like what
we've shown on the screen.
The times proportional
to maybe the sum
of the number of vertices
and the number of edges.
If that makes you uncomfortable
like it does for me because one
of these can kind of
scale on the other,
I think it's always
fine to add more detail.
Right?
So if you want to
say, linear in the sum
of the number of vertices and
edges, that's perfectly fine.
But if you see
this phrase, that's
how you should interpret it.
Hopefully that's a
fair way to put it.
Excellent.
OK.
So last time, we talked about an
algorithm called breadth-first
search--
BFS, for those in the know.
Breadth-first search
is an algorithm.
And the reason we
use the word breadth
is because it's kind of,
remember, we talked about level
sets last time because we talked
about breadth-first search
in the context of
computing shortest paths.
And in particular, we have
our source node all the way
on the left-hand side.
And then breadth-first search
constructed all the nodes
that were distance 1 away.
Right.
That's the first level set, and
then all the distance 2 away,
and then all the distance
3 away, and so on.
So in particular,
the level set L3
isn't visited until
we're completely
done with level set L2.
Today, we're going to define
another algorithm, which
is called depth-first search,
which doesn't do that,
but rather, starts with
its first vertex and just
starts walking all the way out
until it can't do that anymore.
And then it kind of backtracks.
That's one way to
think about it.
And so somehow, in
breadth-first search,
we're like, drawing
concentric circles.
In depth-first search,
we're doing the opposite.
We're like, shooting
outward until we
reach the outer boundary,
and then exploring
the graph that way.
OK.
And these are sort
of the two extremes
in terms of graph search kind
of techniques that are typically
used under the basic building
blocks for algorithms
in graph theory.
So in order to motivate and
think about depth-first search,
we're going to define
a second problem, which
is closely related to shortest
path, but not exactly the same.
And that's the
reachability problem.
So here I have the world's
simplest directed graph.
So the black things
are the edges.
And the circles are the
nodes or the vertices.
And I've marked one
special node in blue.
And his name is the source node.
And now the question
I want to ask
is, what are all of the
other nodes in my graph
that I can reach by
following edges--
directed edges--
starting with the source?
So obviously, I
can get to the node
in the lower right, no problem.
And of course once
I get there, I
can traverse and
edge upward to get
to that second green vertex.
Notice that I was
really sneaky and evil,
and I drew edges in this
graph that might make you
think that the red
node is reachable.
The red one being
on the upper left.
I'm realizing now that
for colorblind people,
this isn't a great slide.
But of course,
because all the edges
from the red vertex on
the left here point out,
I can't actually reach it
from the blue source node.
So the reachability
problem is just
asking, which nodes can I
reach from a given source?
Pretty straightforward, I think.
Of course, there are
many ways to solve this.
Right?
In fact, one way we
could do it would
be to use our previous lecture.
We could compute the shortest
path distance from the source
to all the other nodes.
And then what would the
length of the shortest
path from the source to
an unreachable node be?
Any thoughts from
our audience here?
Infinity.
Thank you, Professor Demaine.
Right.
So in addition to this, of
course, a totally reasonable
question, thinking back to
our shortest path lecture,
there are sort of two
queries we might make.
Right?
One is just what is the
length of the shortest path?
The other is like, what is
the actual shortest path
from the source
to a given vertex?
We can ask a very similar
thing here, which is like, OK.
You tell me that the green
guy is reachable, but how?
Give me a path as evidence
or a certificate, if you
want to be fancy about it.
So in order to do that, just
like last time, remember,
we defined a particular
data structure that
was the shortest path tree.
We can do something
very similar here.
In particular, this is like the
extent of my PowerPoint skills
here.
If I have a
reachability problem,
I can additionally store--
I can decorate every
node in my graph
with one other piece
of information,
which is the previous
node along some path
from my source to that thing.
Right?
And just like last
time, if I want
to get an actual path from the
source to w, what could I do?
I can start with w
and then just keep
following those
parent relationships
until I get back to the source.
Then if I flip the order
of that list of vertices,
I get a path from the source
to the target that's valid.
So this object is
called a path tree, just
like we talked-- or a
parent tree, rather.
Just like we talked about
in our last lecture,
there's no reason why this thing
should ever have a cycle in it.
It's certainly a tree.
Right.
So that's the basic
reachability problem.
And in addition to that, we
can compute this object P,
which is going to give me
sort of information about how
any given node was reachable.
There's a slight difference
between the parent
tree that I've defined here and
the shortest path tree, which
I defined last time, which
is, I'm not going to require
that the shortest path I
get-- oh, man-- the path
I get when I backtrack along
my tree P is the shortest path,
it's just a path because for
the reachability problem,
I actually don't care.
Like, I could have a weird,
circuitous, crazy long path.
And it still tells me
that a node is reachable.
Right.
So that's our basic set
up and our data structure.
And now we can introduce a
problem to solve reachability.
Again, we already
have an algorithm
for doing that, which is
to compute shortest paths.
And remember that our
shortest path algorithm
from previous lecture
took linear time
and the size of the input.
It took v plus e time.
Now the question is, can
we do a little better?
The answer, obviously, is
yes, because I just asked it,
and I gave you this problem.
OK.
And here's a technique for doing
that, which unsurprisingly,
is a recursive algorithm.
I'm going to swap my notes
for my handwritten notes.
And this algorithm is
called depth-first search.
And here's the basic strategy.
I'm going to choose
a source node
and label that Node 1 here.
I suppose it actually would
have made sense for me
to actually 0 index this.
Maybe in the slides
I'll fix it later.
But in any event, I'm going
to mark my source node.
And now I'm going to look at
every node, every edge coming
out of that node, and I'm
going to visit it recursively.
So that's our sort of for loop
inside of this function visit.
And then for each
neighboring node,
if I haven't visited it
before, in other words,
I currently haven't
given it a parent.
That's our if statement here.
Then I'm going to say, well,
now they do have a parent.
And that parent is me.
And I'm going to recurse.
You guys see what this is doing?
It's kind of crawling
outward inside of our graph.
So let's do the
example on the screen.
And I purposefully designed this
experiment-- or this example--
to look a little bit different
from breadth-first search,
at least if you choose to
do the ordering that I did.
So here's our graph.
1, 2, 5, 3, 4.
OK.
And let's think about
the traversal order
that the depth-first
search is going to do.
Right.
So here's our source.
And now what does the source do?
It rec-- so let's think
about our recursion tree.
So we have the source
all the way up in here.
And now he's going to
start calling the visit
function recursively.
So.
And I'll go ahead and
number these the same as
on the screen.
Well, he has one
outgoing neighbor,
and it hasn't been visited yet.
So of course, the very first
recursive call that I'll make
is to that neighbor 2.
Now the neighbor
2 also recurses.
Hopefully this kind
of schematic picture
makes some sense, what
I'm trying to draw here.
And well now, the 2 has
two neighbors, a 3 and a 5.
So let's say that
we choose 3 first.
Well, the 3 now
recurses and calls 4.
And then the recursion
tree is kind of done.
So now it goes back out.
And then finally,
well, now, the 3--
or, oh, boy.
Yeah.
The 2 looks at his next
neighbor, which is the 5
and visits that recursively.
Notice that this is not
following the level sets.
Right?
The depth-first search
algorithm got all the way
to the end of my tree
in the recursive calls
and then kind of backed
its way out to the 2
before calling the 5.
These are not the
same technique.
One goes all the way to the end
and then kind of backtracks.
When I say backtrack,
what I mean
is the recursion is
kind of unraveling.
Whereas in breadth-first search,
I visit everything in one level
set before I work my way out.
That distinction make sense?
OK.
So of course, we need to
prove that this algorithm does
something useful.
So let's do that now.
So in particular, we
need a correctness proof.
So our claim is
going to be that--
let's see here-- the depth-first
search algorithm visits all,
I guess reachable v,
and that it correctly
sets the parent in the process.
OK.
So in order to prove
this, of course,
as with almost everything
in this course,
we're going to use induction.
And in particular,
what we're going to do
is do induction on the
distance from the source.
So we're going to
say that, like,
for all vertices in
distance k from the source,
this statement is true.
And then we're going to
prove this inductively on k.
OK?
So we want to do
induction on k, which
is the distance to
the source vertex.
So as with all of
our inductive proofs,
we have to do our base case
and then our inductive step.
So in the base case, k equals 0.
This is a hella
easy case because,
of course, what
is the thing that
is distance 0 from the source?
It's the source!
Yeah.
And take a look at our
strategy all the way
at the top of the slide.
We explicitly set the correct
parent for the source,
and in some sense, visit it
because the very first thing
we do is call visit of s.
So there's kind of
nothing to say here.
Yeah?
Or there's plenty to say if
you write it on your homework.
But your lazy
instructor is going
to write a check mark here.
OK.
So now we have to do
our inductive step.
So what does that mean?
We're going to assume
that our statement is
true for all nodes
within a distance k.
And then we're going to
prove that the same thing is
true for all nodes within
a distance k plus 1.
OK.
So let's do that.
Let's consider a vertex v
that's distance k plus 1 away.
So in other words, the
distance from the source to v
is equal to k plus 1.
And what's our goal?
Our goal is to show that the
parent of v is set correctly.
Yeah?
What was that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, sorry.
I forgot that the distances
in this class are in order.
Yeah.
That's absolutely right.
So it should be the
distance from s to v. Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm really not used to
thinking about directed graphs.
But that's a good fix.
OK.
So now what can we do?
Well, there's this
number is distance here.
So in particular, the
shortest path from s to v.
So remember our argument
last time that essentially,
when we look at shortest path
and we kind of truncate by 1,
it's still shortest path?
That property doesn't
matter so much here.
But at least we
know that there's
another vertex on the path,
which is 1 distance from one
less away.
So let's take u, which
is also a vertex,
to be the previous node on
the shortest path from s
to v. Right.
And so in particular, we know
that the distance from s to u
is equal to k.
And conveniently, of course,
by our inductive hypothesis
here, we know that our
property is true for this guy.
OK.
So now our algorithm,
what do we know?
Well, because our
property is true,
the visit function at
some point in its life
is called on this vertex u.
That's sort of what
our induction assumes.
So we have two cases.
Right.
So when we visit u, we know
that when we call this visit
function, well, remember that
v kind of by definition is
in Adj+ of u.
Right.
So in particular, DGS
is going to consider v
when it gets called.
OK.
And now there's two cases.
Right?
So either when this happens,
P of v does not equal None.
Right.
Well, what does that mean?
Well, it means that we already
kind of found a suitable parent
for v. And we're in good shape.
Otherwise, p of v
does equal None.
Well, in this case, the
very next line of code
correctly sets the parent.
And we're all set.
So in both of these two cases,
we show that the parent of u
was set correctly either
by that line of code
right here or just previously.
And so in either case,
our induction is done.
All right.
I guess given the
feedback I received
from our previous lecture, we
now can end our LaTeX suitably.
OK.
So what did we just show?
We showed that the depth-first
search algorithm can dig around
in a graph and tell me
all of the things that
are searchable, or rather, are
reachable from a given source,
just basically by calling
visit on that source
and then expanding
outward recursively.
OK.
So I think this is
certainly straightforward
from an intuitive perspective.
It's easy to get
lost when you write
these kind of formal
induction proofs
because they always feel
a tiny bit like tautology.
So you should go home and
kind of convince yourself
that it's not.
OK.
So of course, what do
we do in this class?
We always follow the same
kind of boring pattern.
The first thing we do,
define an algorithm.
Second thing we do, make sure
that it's the right algorithm.
What's the third
thing we need to do?
AUDIENCE: Analyze it.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Analyze it.
That's right.
In particular, make sure that
it finishes before the heat
death of the universe.
And indeed, depth-first
research doesn't really
take all that long,
which is a good thing.
So let's think about this a bit.
So what's going to
end up happening
in depth-first
search, well, we're
going to visit every vertex
at most once, kind of
by definition here.
And in each case, we're going
to just visit its neighboring
edges.
Can we ever traverse an
edge more than one time?
No.
Right.
Because the visit
function only ever gets
called one time per vertex.
And our edges are directed.
Right.
So kind think about the from
of every edge, the from vertex
is only ever visited one time.
And hence, every edge is
only visited one time.
Do we ever visit-- ah, yes.
AUDIENCE: Does DFS work
for an undirected graph?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: An
undirected graph.
Absolutely.
So there's sort of different
ways to think about it.
One is to think of
an undirected graph
like a directed
graph with two edges
pointed either
way, which I think
is in this class how we
actually kind of notated it
in the previous lecture.
Yeah.
Actually, that's probably a
reasonable way to reduce it.
So let's stick with that.
Right.
Now, does DFS ever
visit a vertex
that is not reachable
from the source?
Well, the answer is no
because all I ever do
is recursively call
on my neighbors.
And so kind of by definition,
if I'm not reachable,
DFS will never see it.
So if I think about
my runtime carefully,
it's not quite the same
as breadth-first search.
Remember that breadth-first
search took v plus e time.
In depth-first search, it
just takes order e time
because I'm expanding outward
from the source vertex,
hitting every edge
adjacent to every vertex
that I've seen so far.
But I never reach a
vertex that I haven't--
that isn't reachable.
Right?
And so because this only ever
touches every edge one time,
we're in good shape.
And I see a question here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does
BFS reach vertices
that are not reachable?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Does
BFS reach vertices
that are not reachable?
I guess not, now
that you mention it.
But at least in my
boring proof of order
v time last time, our
very first step of BFS,
reserve space
proportional to v, which
is enough to already make
that runtime correct.
Good question.
Yeah.
So I guess the way that
we've talked about it where
you can stretch one little
set after a time, if you
think of that as
reachability, then no.
It doesn't reach
it in the for loop.
But just by construction,
when we started
we already took the time that
we're talking about here.
So notice these run times
aren't exactly the same.
So for example, if my
graph has no edges,
BFS still is going to
take time because it still
has to take order
v time, at least
in the sort of brain-dead
way that we've implemented it
last time.
Obviously, in that
case, we could probably
do something better.
Whereas the way that we've
defined the DFS algorithm,
it only takes edge time.
I see confusion on
my instructor's face.
No?
OK.
Good.
The one thing to
notice is that these
are algorithms for slightly
different tasks in some sense.
The way that we wrote down
breadth-first search last time,
conveniently, it gives
us the shortest path.
There are breadth-first search
algorithms that doesn't.
I think in this class we kind of
think of breadth-first search--
we motivate it in terms of
the shortest path problem.
But it's just kind of a
strategy of working outwards
from a vertex.
Whereas here, the way
we've written down
depth-first search, there's no
reason why the path that we get
should be the shortest.
Right?
So to think of a
really extreme example,
let's say that I
have a cycle graph.
So I get a big loop like this.
Let's say that I do
depth-first search
starting from this vertex.
Well, what will happen?
Well, this guy will call
its neighbor recursively,
who will then call its
neighbor recursively,
who will then call his neighbor
recursively, and so on.
So of course, when I do
depth-first search, when
I get to this vertex,
there's a chain of 1, 2, 3, 4
vertices behind it.
Is that the shortest path from
the source to the target here?
Well, clearly not.
Right?
I could have
traversed that edge.
I just chose not to.
OK.
So that's the depth-first
search algorithm.
It's just essentially
a recursive strategy
where I traverse
all my neighbors,
and each of my neighbors
traverses their neighbors,
and so on.
OK.
So why might we want
to use this algorithm?
Well, we've already solved
the reachability problem.
So let's solve a few more things
using the same basic strategy
here.
So there's some notions
that we've sort of--
actually, in some sense, already
used in the lecture here.
But we might as
well call them out
for what they are, which is
this idea of connectivity.
So a graph is
connected if there's
a path getting from every
vertex to every other vertex.
Right.
Now connectivity
in a directed graph
is kind of a weird object.
Like, for instance,
think of a directed graph
with just two edges.
And one edge goes from u to
v. Then I can get from v to u,
but not vise versa.
That's kind of a weird notion.
So here in 6006 we'll mostly
worry about connectivity only
for undirected graphs
because they're--
the vertices just basically come
in like, big connected clumps.
Or the more technical term
for a big connected clump
is a connected component.
Yeah?
So let's see an example.
So let's say that I
have a graph, which has
an edge and then a triangle.
This is one graph.
Do you see that?
There's a collection
of vertices,
and there's a
collection of edges.
But it has two
connected components--
the guy on the right
and the guy on the left,
meaning that each
vertex here is reachable
from every other vertex here.
Each vertex here is reachable
from every vertex here.
But there's no edge that
goes from the triangle
to the line segment.
Yeah?
And so in the connected
components problem,
we're given a graph
like this guy.
And initially, we
don't, you know--
OK.
When I draw it like
this, it's pretty clear
that my graph has two
connected components.
Maybe my graph-embedding
algorithm failed
and it drew an edge like that.
Well, then maybe--
I don't know-- it's still
pretty obvious that there's
two connected components.
But you can imagine
a universe where
you don't know that a priori.
And the problem
you're trying to solve
is just to enumerate all
these clumps of vertices
that are reachable from one
another in an undirected graph.
And conveniently, we can
use depth-first search
to solve this problem
pretty easily.
Right?
So how could we do it?
Well, in some sense how can we
find one connected component?
So let's say that I just
choose a vertex in my graph.
Well, what do I know
about everything
in its connected component?
Well, it's reachable
from that vertex.
Remember, we just solved the
reachability problem, which
says, if I have a
vertex, I can now
tell you all the
other vertices that
are reachable from this guy.
So I could call DFS on, well,
any vertex of this cycle here.
Call the reachability thing.
And I know that for every vertex
there's one of two things.
Either the vertex has a
parent in that object P,
or it's the source.
So I can very easily find
the connected component
corresponding to that vertex.
Does that makes sense?
Have I found all the
connected components?
No.
I found one.
I found the one corresponding
to the arbitrary vertex
that I just chose.
So how could I fix this?
Well, it's super simple.
I could put a for loop on
the outside, which just loops
over all the vertices, maybe.
And if that vertex is not part
of a connected component yet,
then I need to make a new one.
So then I call DFS
on that vertex.
I collect all the
vertices that I got.
And I iterate.
So this is the algorithm
that in this class
we're going to call full DFS.
By the way, you could
do the same thing
with full breadth-first search.
That's perfectly fine.
Just kind of by analogy here.
Right.
So what is full D--
oh, this chalk is easier.
Well, I'm going to iterate
over all my vertices.
Where I stands for for loop.
Of-- right.
So if v is unvisited,
then I'm going
to do to DFS starting at v. I
guess we used visit to refer
to this in the previous slide.
And that's going
to kind of flood
fill that whole
connected component.
And then I can collect
that connected component
and continue.
We have to be a little bit
careful because, of course,
we don't want like,
checking things--
something to be visited to
somehow take a bunch of time
and make my algorithm
slower than it needs to be.
But of course, we have
a set data structure
that we know can do that
and order one time at least
in expectation.
OK.
So this is the
full DFS algorithm.
It's really simple.
Of DFS because I called
DGS on every vertex.
And it's full because I
looped over all the vertices.
Right.
And so if we think about it, how
much time does this algorithm
take?
It's little bit sneaky
because somehow I
have a for loop over
all the vertices.
Then I could imagine a
universe where I get, like,
vertices times some other number
because there's a for loop,
and then there's
something inside of it.
I think that's how
we're used to thinking
about runtime of for loops.
But in this case,
that actually doesn't
happen because there's never
a case where an edge gets
traversed more than one time.
Because if I'm in one connected
component, then by definition,
I can't be in another
connected component.
Right?
And so what happens
is, in some sense,
this innocent
looking call to DFS--
I suppose if you were like
a LISP or a programmer,
you somehow wouldn't like this.
It has a side effect,
which is that I marked
all the vertices in that
connected component as
"don't touch me again."
Right.
And so implicitly I kind of
removed edges in this process.
So if you think
through it carefully,
the runtime of this
full DFS algorithm
is v plus e time
because every edge is
touched no more than one time.
Kind of amortized over all the
different calls to DGS here.
And there's this for
loop over vertices.
So there's clearly an
order v that you need here.
Does that argument make sense?
So again, we call that linear
in the size of the input.
I'm going to say it as many
times to get it in my own head
correctly.
OK.
Right.
So this is the basic problem.
This comes up all
the time, by the way.
Like, it seems like somehow
a totally brain dead
weird algorithm.
Like, somehow, why would
you want an algorithm that
finds connected components.
Like, why would you even have
a graph that's disconnected
or something?
But of course, that
can happen a lot.
So for instance, maybe you
work at a social media company,
and people have friends.
But like, Eric
and I are friends.
And we're not friends
with anybody else.
We have a-- there's like,
a blood oath kind of thing.
Then that might be not so
easy to find in the graph
because, of course, we're just
two among a sea of students
in this classroom,
all of which have
different interconnections
that are just enumerated based
on the list of edges.
And so even though
like, pictorially, it's
kind of hard to draw a
connecting component algorithm
in a way that doesn't
make it sound kind
of like a useless
technique from the start,
because it's very clear there
are two connected components
there.
Of course, we still have
to be able to write code
to solve this sort of thing.
OK.
So for once, I think I'm almost
on time in lecture today.
So we have one
additional application
of depth-first search
in our class today,
which is sort of on the
opposite end of the spectrum.
So we just talked about
graphs that are undirected
and thinking about cycles.
Now, on the opposite end
we might think of a DAG.
So a DAG is a Directed
Acyclic Graph.
Can anyone think of a
special case of a DAG?
I suppose I should
define it first.
And then we'll come back to
that question, which means
exactly what it sounds like.
So it's a graph that
has directed edges now
and doesn't have
any cycles in it.
So actually, the
graph I gave you
all the way at the beginning
of lecture I think secretly
was an example of one of these.
So let's say that I
have directed edges.
Maybe if I make the
head a triangle,
it's a little easier to see.
I'm not so sure.
In any event, so I'm going to
have an edge up and an edge
to the right, and
similarly, an edge down
and an edge to the right.
This graph looks like a cycle.
But it's not because the only
direction that I can move
is from the left-hand side
to the right-hand side.
So this is a directed graph.
And it doesn't
contain any cycles,
meaning there's no
path that it can
take from a vertex that
gets back to itself
along the directed edges.
OK.
And DAGs show up all the time.
Now that I've defined
what a DAG is,
can somebody give me
an example of a DAG
that we've already seen in 6006?
AUDIENCE: A tree.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: A tree.
At least if we orient all all
the edges kind of pointing
downward in the tree.
Yeah.
Otherwise, it gets
kind of debatable over
whether it's a DAG or not.
If there's no direction
to the edges, then somehow
the definition
just doesn't apply.
OK.
So in processing
directed acyclic graphs,
there's a really
useful thing that you
can do that's going to show
up in this class apparently
quite a bit, which is
kind of interesting to me,
I'm curious to see
what that looks like,
which is to compute a
topological order on the graph.
We're at topologies here.
So as a geometry professor in
my day job, I get all excited.
But in this case,
a topological order
is a fairly
straightforward thing.
Actually, it's
defined on the screen,
and I have bad
handwriting anyway.
So let's just stick with that.
So topological ordering.
So we think of f as a function
that assigns maybe every node
an index in array.
I guess I shouldn't use
the word array here.
But just like an
index, an ordering.
So like, this is
the first vertex.
And this is the second vertex.
And so on.
Then a topological
order is one that
has the properties
shown here, which
is that if I have a directed
edge from u to v, then f of u
is less than f of v.
So in other words,
if I look at the ordering that
I get on my topological order,
u has to appear before v. Yeah?
Let's look at our example again.
So let's give our nodes names.
So here's A, B, C,
D. Well, what clearly
has to be the first node
in my topological order?
A. Right.
It goes all the way
to the left-hand side.
Yeah.
Well, after that it's
a bit of a toss-up.
What do we know?
We know that B and C have to
appear before D. So maybe just
to be annoying, I do A, C,
B-- that's a B-- and then D.
So it's a topological order.
Notice that things
that are on the
left appear in my graph before
things that are on the right,
where the word
"before" here means
that there's an edge that
points from one to the other.
OK.
By the way, are topological
orderings unique?
No.
So if we look at our
graph example here,
ABCD is also a
topological order.
And what that means is
somehow very liberating.
It means that when we
design an algorithm
for finding a topological
order, so there's some design
decisions that we can make.
And we just have to
find one among many.
But in any event, we're going
to define a slightly different
notion of order.
And then we're going to
show that they're closely
linked to each other.
And that is the finishing order.
So in the finishing
order, we're going
to call full DFS on our graph.
Remember, that means we
iterate over all our nodes.
And if we haven't seen that
node yet, we call DFS on it.
And now we're going to
make an order in which
as soon as the call to a
node in that visit function
is complete,
meaning I've already
iterated over all
my neighbors, then
I add my node to the ordering.
That make sense?
It's like a little
bit backward from what
we're used to thinking about.
So it's the order
in which full DFS
finishes visiting each vertex.
Yeah?
And now here's the
claim, is that if we
have a reverse
finishing order, meaning
that we take the finishing order
and then we flip it backward.
That's exactly going to give
us a topological ordering
of the vertices in our graph.
Right.
So let's do that really quickly.
So in other words,
our claim here--
I think, yeah, let's
see-- is that if I
have a directed graph.
So G is a DAG.
Then let's see here.
Then the-- oops.
My notes are backwards.
So I should switch to my--
Jason's notes, which
of course, are correct.
Right.
So if I have a
graph that's a DAG,
then the reverse of
the finishing order
is a topological order.
By the way, we're not going to
prove the converse that if I
have a topological order,
that somehow that thing is
the reverse of DFS, at least
the way that maybe I coded it.
There's a slightly different
statement, which is,
does there exist a DFS
that has that ordering?
But that's one that we'll
worry about another time
around piazza or whatever.
OK.
So let's see here.
So we need to prove this thing.
So what are we going to do?
Well, what do we need to
check is the topological order
is that if I look at
any edge of my graph,
it obeys the relationship that
I have on the screen here.
So in particularly,
we're going to take
uv inside of my set of edges.
And then what I
need is that u is
ordered before v using the
reverse of the finishing order
that we've defined here.
OK.
So let's think back to our
call to the DFS algorithm,
where call this visit function.
Right.
So we have two cases.
Either u is visited
before v. Or it ain't.
Yeah.
So let's do those two cases.
So case Number 1 is, u
is visited before v. OK.
All right.
So what does that mean?
Well, remember that
there's an edge.
Like, pictorially,
what's going on?
Well, there's all kinds
of graph stuff going on.
And then there's u.
And we know that there's
a directed edge from u
to v. That's our picture.
Right?
And maybe there's other
stuff going on outside of us.
So in particular,
well, just by the way
that we've defined that visit
function, what do we know?
We know that when we
call visit on u, well,
v is one of its
outgoing neighbors.
So in particular,
a visit on u is
going to call visit v. And
we know that because well, u
is visited before v.
So currently, v's
parent is l when
I get to you That make sense?
Now, here's where
reverse ordering,
we're going have to keep
it in our head because now,
well, visit of u calls visit
of v. So notice that visit of v
has to complete
before visit of u.
Right?
V completes before visit of u.
Well.
So in reverse, sorting--
in reverse finishing order
here, what does that mean?
Well, if this completes before
the other guy, then they get
flipped backward
in the list, which
is exactly what I want because
there's an edge from u to v.
OK.
So Case 1 is done.
Now we have Case 2, which is
that v is visited before u.
OK.
So now I'm going to make
one additional observation.
OK.
So now I'm going to go
back to my other notes
because I like my
schematic better.
Right.
So what's our
basic picture here?
Oh, no.
I-- Oh, you know what it was?
I printed out
another copy of this.
That's OK.
I can do it off
the top of my head.
OK.
So here's my source vertex.
His name is S. Now, there's a
bunch of edges and whatever.
There's a long path.
And now eventually,
what happens?
Well.
I have a node v. And
somewhere out there
in the universe
is another node u.
And what do I know?
I know that by
assumption, I know
that there's an edge from
u to v. That make sense?
So that's our sort
of picture so far.
OK.
So what do we know?
We know that our
graph is acyclic.
Yeah?
Kind of by definition,
that's our assumption.
So can we reach u from v?
In other words, does there
exist a path from v to u?
So that would look like this.
No because our graph is acyclic,
and I just drew a cycle.
So this is a big X.
There's a frowny face here.
Can't do it.
He has hair, unlike
your instructor.
OK.
So right.
So what does this mean?
Well, OK.
So by this picture, I suppose,
we know that u cannot be
reached from v.
Yeah.
So what does that mean?
Well, it means
that the visit to v
is going to complete
and never see u
because remember, the visit to
v only ever call things that
are kind of descendants of v.
So in other words, visit of v
completes without seeing u.
Well, that's exactly
the same thing
that we showed in
our first case.
Right?
So by the same reasoning,
what does that mean?
In our reverse finishing
order, the ordering from u to v
is preserved.
OK.
So that sort of
completes our proof
here that reverse
finishing order gives me
a topological order,
which is kind of nice.
And so this is a
nice convenient way
of taking all of the nodes
in a directed acyclic graph
and ordering them in
a way that respects
the topology or the
connectivity of that graph.
So we're going to conclude
with one final problem, which
I don't have a slide on.
But that's OK.
And that's cycle detection.
So there's a bit of an exercise
left to the reader here.
So the problem that
we're looking for now
is that we're given
a directed graph.
There's a G in graph, in
case you're wondering.
But now, we don't know
if it's a DAG or not.
And so the question that
we're trying to ask is,
does there exist a cycle in
our directed acyclic graph?
So we're just given our
graph, and we want to know,
can we do this?
Let's think through the
logic of this a bit.
So what do we know?
We know that if our
graph were a DAG, then
I could call DGS,
get the ordering out,
and then I guess flip
its ordering backwards.
So I could compute the
reverse finishing order.
And it would give me a
topological order of my graph.
So if I were a DAG, I would
get a topological order
when I call DFS.
So let's say that I ran DFS.
I got whatever ordering I got.
And now I found an edge the
points in the wrong direction.
I can just double
check my list of edges,
and I find one that does not
respect the relationship that I
see in the second
bullet point here.
Can my graph be a DAG?
No.
Because if my graph were a
DAG, the algorithm would work.
I just proved it to you.
Right?
So if my graph
were a DAG, then I
could do reverse
finishing order.
And what I would get back
is a topological order.
So if I found a certificate that
my order wasn't topological,
something went wrong, and the
only thing that could go wrong
is that my graph isn't a DAG.
Yeah.
Isn't a DAG.
In fact, sort of an exercise
left to the reader and/or
to your section-- do
we still have section?
I think we do, as of now--
is that this is an if
and only if, meaning
that the only time that you
even have a topological ordering
in your graph is if
your graph is a DAG.
This is a really easy fact
to sanity check, by the way.
This is not like, a particularly
challenging problem.
But you should think through
it because it's a good exercise
to make sure you understand
the definitions, which
is to say that if you
have a topological order,
your graph is a DAG.
If you don't have a topological
order, your graph isn't a DAG.
So in other words,
we secretly gave you
an algorithm for checking
if a graph is a DAG at all.
Right?
What could I do?
I could compute reverse
finishing order.
Check if it obeys
the relationship
on the second bullet
point here for every edge.
And if it does, then
we're in good shape.
My graph is a DAG.
If it doesn't,
something went wrong.
And the only thing that
could have gone wrong
is not being a DAG.
OK.
So in other words,
secretly we just solved--
well, I guess the way
that I've written it here,
we've solved the cycle
detection problem here,
which is to say that,
well, I have a cycle if
and only if I'm
not a DAG, which I
can check using this technique.
Of course, the word
"detection" here probably means
that I actually want
to find that cycle,
and I haven't told you
how to do that yet.
All we know how to do so
far is say, like, somewhere
in this graph there's a cycle.
And that's not so good.
So we can do one additional
piece of information
in the two minutes we have
remaining to sort of complete
our story here, which is to
modify our algorithm ever so
slightly to not only say thumbs
up, thumbs down, is there
a cycle in this graph, but also
to actually return the vertices
as a cycle.
And here's the
property that we're
going to do that,
which is following,
which is that if G contains
a cycle, right, then
full DFS will traverse
an edge from a vertex v
to some ancestor of v. I guess
we haven't carefully defined
the term "ancestor" here.
Essentially, if you think of the
sort of the running of the DFS
algorithm, then an
ancestor is like something
that appears in the recursive
call tree before I got to v.
OK.
So how could we prove that?
Well, let's take a cycle.
And we'll give it a name.
In particular, we'll say that
it's a cycle from v0 v1 to vk.
And then it's a cycle,
so it goes back to v0.
OK.
And I can order this
cycle any way I want.
Notice that if I
permute the vertices
in this list in a
cyclical way, meaning
that I take the last few
of them and stick them
at the beginning of the
list, it's still a cycle.
That's the nice
thing about cycles.
So in particular, without
loss of generality,
we're going to assume that v0
is the first vertex visited
by DFS.
What does that mean?
That means, like, when I
do my DFS algorithm making
all these recursive calls,
the very first vertex
to be touched by
this technique is v0.
OK.
Well, now what's going
to end up happening?
Well, think about the recursive
call tree starting at v0.
By the time that
completes, anything
that's reachable from v0 is
also going to be complete.
Do you see that?
So for instance, v0 somewhere
in its call tree might call v2.
And notice that v2 was
not already visited.
So in fact, it will.
For v1 I got to
call v2 and so on.
And in particular, we're going
to get all the way to vertex k.
Right?
So in other words, we're
going to visit a vertex vk.
And notice what's
going to happen.
So remember our algorithm.
In fact, we should probably
just put it up on the screen
would be easier than
talking about it a bunch.
Well, vk is now
going to iterate over
every one of the
neighbors of vk.
And in particular, it's
going to see vertex v0.
Right?
So we're going to
see the edge from vk
to v0, which is an edge
kind of by definition
because we took this
to be a cycle here.
But notice that's exactly the
thing we set out to prove,
namely that full DFS traverses
an edge from a vertex
to one of its ancestors.
Here's a vertex k.
Here's the ancestor v0.
Why do we know that
it's an ancestor?
Well, because v0 was
called in our call tree
before any of these other guys.
Right?
So we wanted an algorithm that
not only did cycle detection,
but also actually
gave me the cycle.
What could I do?
Well, it's essentially
a small modification
of what we already have.
Right.
So-- whoops.
If I want to compute
topological order or whatever,
I can just do DFS.
And that'll tell me like, yay or
nay, does there exist a cycle.
If I want to actually find
that cycle, all I have to do
is check that topological
order property at the same time
that it traversed
the graph during DFS.
And the second that I find an
edge that loops back, I'm done.
And so that's our
basic algorithm here.
And this is a technique
for actually just finding
the cycle in a graph
using the DFS algorithm.